important developing news on the
potential sale of chelsea by roman
abramovich now as i understand it mr
abramovic in the last couple of days has
demanded that the three remaining
bidders for chelsea football club stump
up an extra 500 million pounds if they
want to get their hands on the club now
this process has been going on uh since
uh mr mr abramovic was sanctioned by the
british government
at the beginning of march and at that
point uh just prior to his sanctioning
uh the current chelsea owner had said
that he intended to write off a one and
a half billion pounds loan uh to the
club that had built up over his 19 years
of ownership i am now told that that
writing off that loan for giving that
loan
is now legally not possible because of
mr abramovic's sanctioning and also
because he doesn't personally have
access to the funding required uh to
repay that loan himself now what all
this means is that the three remaining
bidders they are consortia uh headed by
the likes of uh uh sir martin broughton
the former liverpool and british airways
chairman uh and another uh consortium
which is headed by the boston celtics
part owner
steve palucca they have been told that
they will need to find this extra money
in the coming days if they are to win
the auction of chelsea my understanding
is that all three of the bidders remain
in the process and mr abramovic i am
told uh has authorized his associates to
oversee this final stage of the auction
process uh and has told the bidders that
he wants this extra 500 million pounds
to be donated to charity now there are
still lots of financial uncertainties
surrounding the sale process it's not
like 500 million pounds is money you can
easily find uh as loose change down the
back of a sofa jane so whether the three
bidders will be able to come up with
these extra funds in the coming days is
unclear we were expecting a preferred
bidder to emerge in the next few days it
remains to be seen whether that can uh
now happen but as i say the demand from
roman abramovich is that the three
remaining bidders for chelsea football
club do find an extra 500 million pounds
to add to the price that they are
prepared
to buy at last season's champions league
winners